hello ladies and gentlemen
I'm really very delighted
honored to be today here to address this
distinguished audience and I'm really
very grateful for Yale University and
for my friend Stephen for enabling this
opportunity today I will be talking
about a project initiated by my
university yarmouk University in Jordan
under the title saving our culture
heritage by combating illicit excavation
and trade in antiquities and this is an
initiative at the right time from York
University to deal with this very
dangerous depletion of cultural heritage
of Jordan maybe you know most of you
worked in the area and no Jordan you
know this is the land of cultural
heritage where we have a very diverse
very rich cultural heritage and sites
all over the country we have over
200,000 archaeological site scattered
all over the country and represents
culture that start from the prehistory
until today and if you look to the map
of Jordan you can see sites all over
Jordan and that's Linda Jordan really
the name that it deserves the open air
museum Jordan wherever you dig wherever
you go you'll find archaeological sites
and this is an opportunity for the
country and the same time is a big
challenge for Jordan to really preserve
and keep these sites especially from the
illicit excavation and illicit trade
which is really a big big problem for
Jordan thank God we are safe in Jordan
we are in a very turbulent region but
Jordan is a safe country we are out of
this turmoil and the Arab Spring and all
of the head about stories in the middle
east jordan is a safe haven but
nevertheless we are facing really a
serious problems that causing erosion
and depletion of our cultural heritage
mostly because of
this illicit trade and illicit
excavation so monumental sites in Jordan
and removed sites are like they're all
under pressure they are we find really
evidence of illicit excavations by
organized now it's very organized
movement in the country and at different
levels and you can see probably my
colleague from Oxford mention about some
sites in Jordan and I will add some
important site here in Petra you have a
list excavation as well as an important
psyche like khodaro jaraj but over also
an remote sites in the north in the
South wherever you go in Jordan really
we have this serious problem and the
problem is that people engaged in this
illicit activities are the guards
themselves so are supposed to protect
the site and people from different
social levels from you know normal
villagers up to really officials and
people really should be engaged in the
protection of the Heritage rather than
selling illegally this heritage so when
you look at this excavation you think
this is an officially excavation by the
Department of Antiquities Jordan it's
not the case this is an illegal
excavation you know in minute of the day
we will be gathered and do their on
excavation and the dog collection and
sometimes they use bulldozers which
caused really a great deal of damage and
destruction to the sides this is why we
really lost a great deal of our culture
heritage and i have a presentation about
the lost treasures of jordan will find
really treasures of jordan in the black
market maybe you heard about the last
one a very important
every called the Jordan codices which is
as may be important as the Dead Sea
Scrolls they are now not in Jordan they
are outside Jordan they are partly in
Israel and part in London but we have
maybe three pieces out of 70 of these
very early Christians documents which
may be you know at the end proved to be
very important as may be equally
important to the dead sea scrolls with
that not just that but also we have many
lost treasures that found in the black
market and in some of private
collections in the in the West this is
why we initiated this project from
yarmouk University a team of researchers
applied for funding from the United
States Agency for International
Development we managed to get the
funding and technical assistance for a
project where we really put together a
team to study this illicit excavation
phenomena try to understand the scale of
the problem the motives why the people
are engaged in this weather this because
of really ignorance lack of
understanding of the value of cultural
heritage ideology we don't know why
there are really a combination of
different reasons and also to try to
find after understanding the root causes
of this phenomena to find the solutions
and solutions at different levels
whether legal or try to implement some
awareness campaigns or working with the
local community which is really the key
the local community and working and
cooperating with the local community is
very important approaching this project
and the project is built up by doing a
country survey try to understand the
scale of the problem and then understand
the root causes and after that
working with focus group in different
archaeological sites in the North in the
middle and the south of the country we
have selected some sites and working
with local community try to analyze and
understand really what's happening and
these are the main activities of the
project the country survey and working
on the legislation's in the country so
we will have a proposal for the
amendment of the Jordan antiquity law we
think this is there are serious flows in
in the legislation and try to come up
with really an awareness campaign
organized with the Ministry of Education
so we'll produce like an awareness kit
for schools and for university so we
organized also a series of workshops
with the target groups like you know
targeting customs the police all people
dealing with cultural heritage and the
local community through a series of
workshops and we are working now on the
amendment of the law so we'll have a
proposal for an amended law to be
presented to the Parliament through the
channels to be approved and we will
implement our educational awareness kit
probably next month thank you very much
you